hey I was going for this my name is Pete
welcome to in real life so for today's
episode we're going to make the three
monsters of amnesia
there's actually four monsters but that
one is invisible so that would be stupid
but anyway I thought I'll turn myself
into the monster and see what we can
come up with so why don't you hang out
so yeah here we have the first monster
the servant or mr. face or mister what
the [ __ ] face is probably better name
I took some images already here's our
our base one and that's our base I'm all
about that face let's start by making me
bald cuz I'll make myself all baby okay
there we go
I'm bold a [ __ ] ball what a beautiful
skull I would have what I want to touch
it now let's do that [ __ ] weird jaw
drop thing when he sees that is I mean
he is chasing the main character of the
game obviously we have a jaw dropping
ass that should be the real story of the
game now I already took the liberty of
taking a picture of my mouth beautiful
thank you yes I know let's use that and
I'm gonna be perfect but we're not going
for perfection baby we're going for
almost [ __ ] barely passable how about
that
[Music]
boy that's fault
it kind of looks like a bird or some
[ __ ] I don't have them now yeah we're
gonna translate the drinkers I don't
know why I said it like that I'm so
sorry real men real men embrace the
wrinkles make it more believable
all right well it's getting places I'm
gonna [ __ ] know I don't I don't tell
you uh eyebrows get [ __ ] away I press ok
the ice those sexy fish eyes Wow amazing
so far this looks like a failed facelift
or some [ __ ]
very proud
yep looks great ten out of ten would
Bank more wrinkles
[Music]
okay so yes these [ __ ] I think I
don't know how to do that 100% but I'm
gonna try
so let's do that okay cool
I realized I'm basically doing the
version of a makeup tutorial here it's
not a tutorial and you'll have
nightmares afterwards
[Music]
what is an amnesia monster without his
beautiful teeth do we have it yes we
have
let's transplant maybe surgeon pills in
the house baby
[Music]
some final detailing baby
oh is this a trick baby alright so
there's two final results let's take a
look at before before yeah disgusting
after relief tzimmes a policeman let's
see what are your best thing about this
viewing assist your twin daddy material
you look like a duck FairPoint for our
criticism holy [ __ ] did not expect that
let's go on to the next favor shape
that's a beautiful face next amnesia
monster is of course the Justine one
okay I can do that here's our picture
that we're gonna work on first of all
let's make myself bald baby because
according to old horror games ever Paul
people are terrifying why did I feel so
[ __ ] hard making myself bold [ __ ]
their ball what even do but I don't care
what the hair say I'm [ __ ] bald next
step - and being ugly as [ __ ]
get rid of them my bras baby ten outta
ten baby make the mouth big baby big
mouth scary face yes
alright so the eyes are not existing
Adam yeah that looks pretty shitty 100
percent acceptable low well I like the
first one look decent god I [ __ ] out I
look like one of those shitty horror
memes or some [ __ ] god dammit my life is
over now let's go for the crying mascara
effect my favorite yes and so emo you
already know I'm bleeding blood get to
tell I am a bro
hey that random baby alright there you
go I'm failed [ __ ] failed
what are you why I'm sorry
stupid I thought this one would be easy
look how many wrinkles how can I compete
with that I just can't I just
[Music]
so this is the other the third amnesia
monster mr. tooth
I guess teeth we're doing it I don't
give a [ __ ]
look we could we can make it happen I
have a great feeling about this all
right we need to take the [ __ ] hand
piece of [ __ ] and then we need to shape
it and accordingly this will be great
this will be a learning experience for
us all in life all right I successfully
made my face look like a pancake I think
that it that is definitely a win thank
you no thank you life wow isn't this
going great so far I am so happy this is
the start of something new it's me and
you
Nenana and so what if I like High School
Musical they're a great great music
[Music]
oh my god I did not mean for this
I would make ad with this if I could
because it's me why'd we agree on things
take those beautiful teeth and make some
heart baby I'm so [ __ ] lazy it's
[ __ ] amazing look at this look at
that that looks great oh my god I want
to [ __ ] stab my anus with a pencil oh
yeah I'm so tired I was a little bit
over my head on this episode I think I
should have just focused on one instead
of trying to do three cuz it does take
time if you want to make a look properly
instead of looking like this [ __ ] but
still I really do enjoy making these
episodes I have a lot of fun photos
[ __ ] with you
great photoshopping thank you guys
watching liberalised if you want more
and suggest me what else you want maybe
a Photoshop in the future maybe I'll
Photoshop your face because you can't
have a straight face without sacrifice
stay awesome bros
[Music]
so fart is so beautiful oh my god I'm
proud of myself should we make the face
the same [ __ ] weird fat face yes